okay hi everyone we are back after a bit
of a Hiatus for our summer school and
high school program
uh
and we're here doing a both language
design review part of our language
completeness and consistency series
all right various topics today count
distinct
okay so this is a pretty small thing
um we added a second argument uh which
is a succinctness right
um and we didn't document it and I think
that was probably just an oversight but
I wanted to make sure we all agreed with
that before actually the futurizing the
documentation
sounds sensible to me anybody got an
objection to this
this is the distinctness test that is
these things are considered indistinct
if this test succeeds correct
um
correct
is that clarified in the in the
documentation
um
I think you should say they should be
considered not distinct
okay
I assume this assumes that the test is
transitive
uh yes
right I mean it has the same issue as as
delete duplicates
so you should make a comment that it
assumes it implicitly assumes it's
transitive
okay
making sense yes and presumably this is
I mean it should also be described as
as the length of delete duplicates of
lists
right
in fact it's
uh well is that not I could have sworn
that was in the notes I was trying to
read
by and count distinct for the second
argument right and so I have the the
relevant example right there in the
agenda because
uh
I see okay so this is a minor luxury to
be able to have count distinct
with that second with that test right
that's sort of making it equivalent to
delete duplicates which also has fine to
me any objections
let's move on
part assignment to non-existent keys
right
so
um
you know you can assign to a
non-existent key in an association
and uh right you can do part assignment
to a non-existent key
and that will create the key in the
association
which is different from other types of
Expressions let's do that don't they no
if I say list well the the used to at
least
the point would be if you had a list of
length three and then you say list part
four equals something I know
huh
I believe there was a time maybe it was
in version 0.8 before version one where
that works okay I am not familiar with
any version in which that has worked
it's never worked since I've been here
and the issue you know what it worked in
smpm maybe that's it yeah because what
the problem with it is if you do lists
of say Max machine number equals D
you're in trouble
I mean you don't know what to fill in
the only possibility would be filling in
the you know we'll be adding the very
next element
yeah
go ahead what
it seems like a very weird operation it
doesn't seem very useful yeah
but this thing does seem useful I didn't
know it worked but it does seem useful
right so no I think the question is
oh I see yeah okay fine
the association case does not have the
issue of we don't know what to fill in
an intermediate uh elements
correct
um
so
right now is that mean
well that that's why it's labeled
completely crazily
it basically just ignores
uh uh all the parts after the key
and just assign that just seems wrong
right
um
right so as I note right there in the
agenda I think the second Behavior I
pointed out is is
just a bug
um
uh now the first behavior
is is not documented but there is code
that uses it and like uh you know
um okay so this case where it's not a
part but a sub value basically that we
all agree should work yes we all agree
that should work and
um
and that behavior is also documented
what about what about can't you provide
I'm not sure if this is documented but
can't you provide multiple arguments in
the sub-value
and it will sort of go multiple levels
um I don't think so but I don't think
you ever create empty associations
so if you had
a with an m with an S Association you
could assign to the nested sound value I
think a equals this
and then we say
and then that then a is this
and then we say a of quote C comma
quotes d
equals X
and what if you do a c Association key
feed does not exist what does that mean
if I say a of C equals x then that
better work
yes
but what if you do AOC equal empty
Association and then you do ACD
I think in that case it would work
so I think I I believe that you can fill
in keys if you can feeling missing keys
but you cannot create nested levels
which which I think generally seems
reasonable
yes
right and
right and these are always keys so if
you did
a a of part of of Open Bracket C comma
one
then that would
look for a key named one I presume yes
yeah
okay so the behavior with sub values
seems reasonable and should be
documented is it
the the fact that you can assign
uh
uh you know the fact that you can create
a new key is documented the fact that
you can undocumented
um
I'm not sure I would have to double
check exactly but you guys will chase
that
okay now what we're talking about is the
partest time in the case of this
right and the part assignment case will
be specific to either the key wrapper or
a string correct correct
well if there's one useful case I can
mention which is if you have an
association which is nested in some
stuff with parts you could have you know
expression part one two three
a equals something yeah I agree that's
that's sort of that first example that
there's that's why I did it as all comma
D instead of oh okay yes okay instead of
uh instead of just D and I think yes the
reason Julio is here is because I'm
aware of
Etienne having used this idiom and uh
yes
um right look my take is that we should
document this now what's your concern
about consistent with other
different which is both documented
so so no no okay
right I'm saying that assigning creating
Keys via part and uh creating Keys via
sub-value assignment are not the same
operation and so why not if well
um because they
you know
um well it there are if if you attach
side effects to that assignment right
then one one will fire in one case and I
suppose
[Music]
what's that why are they different
I'm presumably colon equals Works in
both cases why are they different
well because well because right one is a
down value type assignment and one is a
set is a part type assignment right it's
right I mean you can't assign down
values using part assignment right
so if you look at practical usage part
is strictly more powerful because you
can deal with more expression types
while the down values only works with
the nested Association then they have to
be consistent with associations right
which means we should support the part
case
this case
that randomly works
seems just weird
and it seems like it should fail here
yes
that should fail yeah I think which we
should do for part we should treat you
know strings or key things with a key
wrapper as referred to associations and
they're effectively equivalent you know
at least at that level as you know
association with just the single bracket
I agree
so
um
the uh
I mean I I would argue it's a bit crazy
idea yeah yeah like so we have one
reason why you want to use part which is
like more powerful in terms of like
accessing both keys and indexed parts
what's the reason why you should prefer
the other one maybe is that you can
actually create nested associations
using down values
we want to make minimal changes here
we've got something that's basically
working we've got a corner case that's
been identified that's kind of weird
let's get rid of that corner case and
declare victory
let's not build some elaborate subsystem
that I don't think we need what we have
is working
you know I'm telling you the the
Practical use case is that if I already
know that I want a nested Association
then right now I have to say you know a
equal empty Association then a of uh b
equal empty Association then a of c
equal empty station and then a of B of C
yeah
what are you suggesting
that only for the down value one which
is a kind of you know that only works
for nested associations if a is an
association and if you say a of B of C
of D you could actually create all the
levels
so that that would make the the down
value also useful in its own right
because it will have one power that the
part doesn't have
I don't know if it is stupid clicks
by the way standard on live stream
comments that that um
wow wait a minute a assignment with up
to
that seems pretty wild to me
wow we don't have any range assignments
do we
so if I say uh you can assign to spans
span
okay so if I say list of five
semi-summary eight
equals x then that'll do exactly okay
that's nice you could even do something
like like list of five common colonate
equals reverse of list of five colon
colonate and I think it will doesn't
that basically subset map
right but there's a there's there's a
bizarre syntax with this that that I
think would run amok with up to and that
is if that list
I mean 582 is two elements right so if
you have a list of two elements in it
sequentially uses those elements
I think that could get a bit bizarre
with up to detectives in those cases
correctly I I think that the the span
case is a good version of the up to you
can do up to like with Spam
I mean with span okay let's come back to
our previous discussion so Julio was
arguing that there might be something
nice about being able to have the
multi-case
like your your AC comma D working
without saying a of c equal empty
Association
the one that says this this one the
pales without having this one here the
place yep yeah
well I agree that's not completely crazy
boy that's exactly the semantics of SMP
how horrifying
how many years have been 40 something
years later we come back to exactly the
same thing
uh now then in SMP there was this crazy
thing with this attribute that I called
Tia t-i-e-r
that
determine whether okay so here's where
it gets funky okay
at least in the s p case I don't know
maybe we've got a different case where
you say this
now to us that is meaningless right
because a of C evaluates does it not
correct is that right and the L value
case that it still evaluates yes
um
which is why when you're defining sub
values you often need a hold pattern
is that documented
uh I presume I think so I I would have
to double check I got very upset about
documentation
with um uh at the summer school finding
out lots of things were really under
documented
um
okay
um all right so then the question is
whether this
case here
should work
let's investigate making it work I don't
see a harm in it
seems useful even if it's very
uh
sort of retro retro in some level it's
just FYI I looked it up it's the second
properties and relations example on sub
values that you should use hold pattern
to prevent things okay okay
uh okay
it might also be going to possible
issues
it could
um okay what else is there to discuss
here
so I think we're concluding this case
should not work
this case could work
and everything else stays the same
yes
okay
what the heck is that oh there's the
Prototype build
but somebody should screencap and report
that
it's wild see that Carla do you have a
screenshot okay
okay next item okay
wow right look at this wild thing okay
yeah this is uh this is another This is
Wild on the screen but then before I was
looking at the wildness of the content
here yes
right so this is uh this is well this
was an internal bug report the previous
thing was an external user bug report
this was inspired by an internal user
bug report which
thought that the first input was a bug
but apparently there are some
uh functions that if if you go to part
minus the length plus one they treat
that as the head so you see here we have
an empty list and you map F at minus one
and it gives it applies F to the Head
and and the second input if you you know
we have a list of length three even with
heads false
these do not take the heads option right
because this is map add map app and it
right that is part number minus one and
for some absolutely Bonkers reason it
thinks that part minus one is the head
right because the length of it my length
of list minus one is zero right so so
minus one would be the the bug
[Laughter]
I mean it's wild but it looks like a bug
so so Jack okay all right yeah so so
uh you know there was a certain level of
consistency between uh certain class of
functions right we found three functions
if Danny if Danny is here he he he spoke
up in defense of this behavior of just
saying well you know if if part zero is
is the head then if you start counting
from the end then you know minus one
crazy but no we can't do that because we
don't do that in part if you give minus
one exactly well that's adjustment in in
our part normalization should always be
consistent
okay so I mean that's abstract also not
return the head
with minus one
yeah right that's straight yeah part and
extract uh and delete all agree so it
can't possibly but no I mean it just
okay I mean I I agree with you but since
there was a internal disagreement to the
the uh you know Danny was invited I
don't know if he's just being quiet or
if he if he was not available for some
reason but you know Danny spoke up in
defense of this Behavior so I you know I
felt obligated to you know does
everybody know what it looks like in the
code is this just a bug I think it's
just a bug somebody just didn't think of
this mm-hmm
yeah I think that's that's probably
because there's special code in part the
treats the positive and the negative
case separately
um okay and that probably just
maybe we should make an inline function
that does that correctly and and just
use that everywhere
fine
all right let's move on
okay
all right so
um
the save now buttons uh and this is why
we wanted to be in the Prototype build
oh somebody evaluated those things I
mean you'll want to reevaluate them uh
yeah
right so we we
um
right so you see it it says data not
saved saved now this was a whole
discussion we had about
three maybe four months ago
um and right it used to say data not
stored or data not a notebook store now
but then the sub menus were you know two
out of the three possibilities didn't
store it in the notebook so now we added
per the discussion from last time we
reworded that first thing and we added a
cloud privately
um
so you can you can save it either with
public or private permissions
um one thing it struck me as a bit odd
that we say data not we changed the main
thing to say data not saved but we
continue to use store
in
uh the I agree so
okay
um let me think
audio is another place to where this
menu appears and and
they use stored not only for the menu
items but for the tooltip on the
on the icon
change storage location
uh Julio uh I mean Carlo is here
um okay can you speak to the audio case
yeah I mean we've established that as a
kind of different case because uh audio
file and audio in Notebook are two valid
modalities while for this summary box
um the case is different
um right right so so I'm not sure it is
super element for the discussion for the
summary boxes right because with with
the with the summary box case right even
though you're saving it externally
when you actually use it as input it's
bringing it in core whereas in audio
right it's when it's you know when it's
storing it in a file or whatever then
it's now sort of a fundamentally
different thing right you have a
different input form you're now uh
processing it out of core Etc
sorry say that again with audio right
the difference between uh
[Music]
uh with audio if you change the storage
location from notebook to file say then
you've changed you fundamentally changed
the object from in-core to out of core
if you then apply any processing
functions to it it will
take place out of core so it's sort of a
different
operation why did we change this from
data not stored store now to data not
saved save save now why do we change
that because
um
uh because uh when when it was because
all right so the history was right
originally there was no no things right
objects were either yeah yeah right then
we added the ability to the the it was
Data not a notebook store now and there
was exactly one action which was
embedded into
the notebook and then we added you know
local object and Cloud object and it
still said data not in Notebook store
now and that didn't make any sense
because two out of the three options
didn't put it in the notebook
um
and so that's why we
know I mean I don't understand you have
I mean nothing is saved until you save
what is really going on in the kernel
right now that data is happily there
well okay is it the case if I pick up
that
no it's not there I mean if you pick up
that thing right now and try to use it
as input it will fail right
maybe detail here
um why does the summary box not use the
same mechanism that is that then when
you click embedding line in an Outlook
this box can retrieve the data from the
kernel why is that not used in the
interpretation function of this or the
equivalent of in the interpretation
function I feel like that operation
would be possible maybe
um well I I tried it and it does work it
has a it would be a kind of confusing
Behavior because then you don't know
when the Reconstruction would work and
when it wouldn't exactly yeah but there
are situations where it could work
saying
maybe but it's kind of annoying I I've
been burnt by it many times where I copy
that
you know object there
without having saved it and it doesn't
work
well that's why I originally wanted that
that stripe to be red so it would be
very obvious that you know you can't use
it yeah I mean we don't want it okay
what is really going on is it data not
included
well it's it's it's I mean but no I mean
even if it's not
uh you can't pick it up and expect the
data to be there
right because it's not saved anywhere
then in the kernel memory right it's
right but but this object that you're
looking at here is data not included
like batteries
so I'm saying this object
but even if you but even if you save it
in a cloud object that the data isn't
included
I understand
right well so what is it so Scott what
is it the data is not accessible from
this object itself
right that's what's really going on
is the data accessible to this object
itself
right I suppose
that's what it is
if I'm not mistaken
I don't I don't I don't think that's a
useful description for you I understand
I want to understand what's actually
going on
then let's understand what we tell
people
all right okay so what's actually going
on is the data is not available from
this blob correct
it's kind of like underlying data is not
present
but that's very weird
um
yeah because then pressing the button
would suddenly make it present by Magic
and it's a bit confusing to me well I
want to go back to this possibility that
within the session that the thing is
still alive
[Music]
code and I think that is a potentially
fuel line change
yeah I think this is something we hadn't
considered at the time but I don't see
any reason why it couldn't work
modular things like the large you know
if it overruns the size thresholds or
something right but but I think but I
think you'll end up then with other
undesirable Behavior like
you know when when you when you quit the
kernel or when it's no longer available
then then you're going to have the same
thing as a Dynamics and many other
things
uh well yeah well the output the output
size limit can avoid this because
there's you can look at Dollar session
ID to uniquely determine whether it's in
a new session or not I don't know that
there's any such thing currently in
these we could do things we could do
that here right we could add that okay
so let's think about that case Okay so
really what this is is data not
permanently saved
save now
that will be less confusing I mean if it
said data not permanently saved but
nevertheless it did work within the
notebook
now okay so let's think about three
cases right
okay it's going to work within the
notebook but it says data not
permanently saved saved now great that's
fine
next case
you didn't save
and you bring this back and and you're
looking at this notebook again and it
knows that it doesn't know
get what I'm saying
yeah in that case it should just be read
and say this doesn't work
right
data not available
right I mean if you quit your kernel we
can see what it does I think I think
that's
I know you might need to like
okay let's try going I think where it
should be enough
I know maybe you need to yeah and you'll
need to if you click that if you click
the save now it'll well well yeah
certainly if you click on it but I think
me um
dynamically I don't know maybe dollar
session ID is not a sufficient Dynamic
trigger
yeah I think if you like close to no
Save The Notebook close and reopen it'll
well okay let's handle both of these
points does dollar session ID Rev on a
kernel quit I think it does doesn't it
I think it usually does yes I I
certainly have built other interfaces
that work and I can't explain why this
one is not triggered
okay all right so let's just consider it
a bug for right now
assume that this should work
okay so let's go ahead and move
reopen that what the heck is this
wow well it's 13 I mean that's the
Prototype build
but somebody probably wants to pay
attention to that that's probably um I
think maybe
no this is that isn't
nope that is a stone
what if you
what's that even if you press the button
did you just try that and you didn't do
anything
okay
well that's fine Behavior
yeah
but I think it should do something even
in this case here
it should say
I mean there is a state where it says
the data is not available so I I don't
know if there's some sort of question
issue so then there's some some bug here
so we need to track that down
yep okay
but
okay so look we've got several actions
here one
do the fuel line change that color is
suggesting to make it so that this can
be used change it to Great data not
permanently permanently saved save now
I would encourage a small additional
space here to make it easier to read
after that period because this is right
now further away than this is from that
get what I'm saying
do you understand what I'm saying I
didn't quite follow that so let me go
through it again that space there
between save now and the on the icon is
bigger than the space between the first
sentence and the second sentence that
seems wrong
didn't know what I'm saying well a bit
more space there and a bit less space
here
does that make sense
I understand what you're saying I'm not
sure that I necessarily agree with it
but well why don't you agree
I didn't say I don't agree I said I'm
not sure I agree okay fine
if you think about it and don't agree
tell me why
the
okay but otherwise I think data not
permanently saved space save now okay
yeah that's just getting kind of long
but
well yes it is but I think I mean
we could go slightly smaller graphically
okay so let me point this out again
given the behavior we're now describing
this could go even a point size smaller
am I making sense
um and no I don't think so because the
key Point per you know the fact that
it's not actually saved is the key point
right I mean people need to know that
it's gone I'm just saying that because
they don't actually need to know within
the session they only need to solve that
but that no no no that is exactly the
point I disagree with they need to know
that the moment they quit the kernel
that data is gone
or or or you know they'll be annoyed
like you are when they haven't saved it
and it's you know and it's no longer
available
you know
it kind of makes me wonder
it's probably too late by the time
you're quitting
you know there are two actions you quit
this notebook
and then you quit the kernel or the
other way around
I assume just like it says you know
notebooks have not been saved you know
you've got an Untitled whatever it is
it obvious that we shouldn't be telling
people on session quit on on application
quit
that there are things like this that are
unsaved
okay
I don't really see how that's possible I
mean right how would it distinguish this
case from you know any of a gazillion
other Dynamics but I mean
well it's not obvious the Dynamics you
know if we could tell people use same
definitions that might make them very
happy
because they are going to be toasted if
they quit
they didn't save enough State they try
and rehydrate doesn't come back to life
right they're annoyed now you know in
the past like 30 years ago when we first
had all these mechanisms
we we just didn't have the option to say
we didn't have things like the cloud and
local objects and all that kind of thing
am I making sense
so I just want to review this
possibility
is it possible and Lou this is more on
you than anybody else
to tag things like this that are
trailing unsaved items
and make essentially a queue of those
now clearly there will be weird cases
like you close the notebook
without having saved things but you
didn't close the kernel so in principle
you could still get those things back
am I making sense
right in fact you absolutely can
I understand but that works now for
things like cell labels
right the in-out labeling pops back to
life if you save and reopen a notebook
in the same kernel session
okay okay let's talk about a possible
logic possible thing here okay
that we actually try and make a are you
sure basically thing
that that does roughly the following if
it turns out you've only got you know
two megabytes of stuff that it would
take to save everything locally in your
in the notebook then just says hey you
want to save it locally in The Notebook
with save definitions or whatever else
in fact this raises the question should
manipulate have another thing that says
data not saved
or
something just like this rather than
manipulate not having any visual
indication that save definitions is
false
uh I mean it's perfectly reasonable to
have a manipulator can be fully working
and rely on the global definition of a
user-defined function
I don't think that's a state that needs
to be warned against I think that's a
state we should just Embrace that when
you bring it back it's not going to work
anymore
well when you bring it back and decide
to change the function definition it
will work no no no no or you haven't run
the function or you haven't run and then
you get that behavior I mean those are
that behavior is not good that behavior
is Its Behavior might be exactly what
the user wants
no no no because the developer has
carefully decided that this this symbol
should only have a definition in certain
circumstances no no wait wait a second
wait a second what is it the fact that
the manipulation is just pink without an
explanation it's really no good
there's no pinking in the examples that
I'm imagining
well what does it do and it just does
the wrong thing right if save
definitions is false
and it's about it does the thing that
you've told it to do
it's not the wrong thing wait a second
wait a second if x equals one is set
externally and then you have a dynamic
of x
what does the dynamic of X do if the x
equals one hasn't been evaluated
it shows you the current value of x
whatever that is which is x in that case
sure if x is it'll go pink
um
I mean I can demonstrate I mean if we
just say x is a graphic then Dynamic of
X will not go pink
okay Dynamic there are cases which will
go because that is not every case Steven
that's the point I'm making no I
understand but this case we'll go pink
yes
right well then when people see that in
a notebook they are very un they just
clue you know they have no idea what
happened
they have no idea that there's something
you're supposed to evaluate there
and what does hovering over the pink say
that's very bad cell context backtick
rare other than the cell context
backtick is it still very bad
pretty bad I mean it's not great
so it doesn't tell you if you're an on
you know if you're just a user where
somebody sent you this manipulate and
you have no idea how it works it's
extremely unhelpful
right but
it's uh I mean okay look let's let's
okay let's take this to the user
assistance meeting I think this probably
isn't the right meeting for this not the
right set of people
I'm claiming that we should do something
different with save definitions
with the with the UN unsaved definitions
I mean does it know
it doesn't know you're saying Lou that
it could be correct that this simply
says symbolic is that right yes
absolutely
and therefore that it doesn't know
what is it
the dynamic has no idea why it's pinking
other Dynamic doesn't know that it is
right only the front end knows that it's
pinking
you know in a case like this one here
there is an argument that it should say
things like you know
it should give some indication that
there might be a definition that's worth
running
even if it doesn't know that there is
such definition because
if if it's I mean
in in the manipulate case maybe because
we have sort of a whole bunch of you
know architecture around us but you know
this is uh you know at the level of
dynamic no that that's just not right I
mean that's like saying that you know
Roblox should have a special tooltip
that says you know maybe you need to you
know make sure that the Roblox has a
single flat list and yeah
hmm
let's consider the manipulate case at
least
the dynamic case I agree is a little bit
more under the hood
but I want to come back to the the case
of um
uh
so for unstored things like summary
boxes
um I thought there was already an idea a
concept for
you know when these things exist and
need to be filled in at some point the
user could choose to fill them in
whether that's proactively on the user's
part or whether it's prompted by us I
thought there was already a concept
I think that was something something in
the toolbar
um but but I I I which I see
which I see you have turned off I mean
we need we'd need John for that
um John uh is is uh John would know what
the but he's uh he's out today so which
is why he's not here he normally would
be here
um so I would know what I well the the
status of that you know save things uh
right now we have a notion of a safe
things thing which could either come up
on Notebook clothes or session or
application close
sure but I don't know that it could come
up on Colonel quit
I understand it probably could actually
the front end can watch for that
all right okay but okay about what we're
doing here okay so that that's the thing
we need to make sure I don't know if
it's in this meeting or if it's in user
assistance can somebody determine that
can we pick please
the discussion of those
of closing actions and so on
um I'll discuss with John seriously I
think it probably should be a news
assistant because it has a bunch of ux
stuff and we're not doing ux in these
meetings
okay so with respect to what we're
dealing with here
I think
we've agreed this thing is going to be
preserved so it's just going to say data
all right it can say data not saved here
these are not saved is that really
enough okay I have one more complaint
which is I don't understand why the font
for these is so incredibly small
uh that's because that has to do with
that that
doesn't scale and I don't know if if
that's okay so it's a potential bug so
we have to talk to John about it well I
I think it's a question of Luke for Lou
of I don't know what you're trying to
say etai I don't remember any issues
here so so if if it right if you set the
notebook Zoom to a hundred percent
you'll see that the the the pop-up and
the Stripe have the same font size and
then when you increase the zoom the the
the the uh
what's that I think they should magnify
together or not I think it's a bug yeah
fine they magnify together I'm a happy
camper
okay
um can I just raise something we should
put in user assistance which is a bunch
of these ancillary things not magnifying
or magnifying
and I would kind of argue that there
should be a preference to setting for
whether these ancillas or whatever one
calls them
you know
magnify or not
there have been lots of conversations
about this the toolbar the the
predictive interface the image editors
but why don't we just make a preference
setting because I mean basically what it
is is if you and it could be something
that can be set on a you know style
sheet for a notebook you know I I agree
that for accessibility that might be a
useful thing I just don't know if the
designs as they are are amenable to you
know will just work under magnification
or how much effort it will be to make it
right right and each right and each one
of these things it would need to write
the individually updated to opt into
this preference which you know I'm uh
right right yes all I'm saying I'm not
saying it's not worth doing I think that
they're they're you know there are
strong opinions on both sides I mean
right right and so which is why I think
this preference is used is a useful
thing but it's not going to be an
instant fix it's also possible that if
John were here he would say well then
you should be interacting with your OS
resolution and application settings and
not any particular applications I can't
speak for John of course yeah I know I
can I can speak from you know there was
a summer school student who had sort of
vision problems and who I know did not
set their OS magnification because it
broke a bunch of other stuff
but that meant because other
applications don't actually work with
the OS magnification probably
including the OS itself in some places
yes
what osm they may ask I think that was
Windows okay
[Music]
um
yeah okay so we can right okay so so so
the main so the main question I think
well there's the there there's the
advertise limiter that we still need to
discuss but before we move on from
summary boxes are we keeping store or
are we making it safe to be consistent
with the stripe
I think we should keep store I really do
I think okay
right I don't have a pony in this
particular race I just it it just the
inconsistency sort of jumped out at me
as I was reviewing the lose changes and
I wanted to get confirmations because
there's multiple options there in bed
versus store I think it's okay okay
all right what about the output size
limiter right so evaluate the range to
the six and you'll see that there's a
store uh
store I think it's store full expression
in Notebook so it's like the old button
which did not have a pop-up and we never
sort of explicitly discussed this
um do we want to turn this also into a
sub menu
and that does that uh you know do do we
use I think it's interesting to be able
to store this
in that way I would love to be able to
do the same kind of thing with images
you know with giant images in a notebook
that will be super easy actually working
on something like that updating the
image boxes to
uh have compressed storage that
potentially is optional using them bed
button
sorry not just compression but I mean
the basic point is that I am regularly
getting you know half gigabyte notebooks
and things are getting very slow to save
and all that kind of stuff yep and I
really want those things to be
externalized and in fact what I would
like is you know an option there to
externalize in the same directory or in
some specified subdirectory
so so Julio is it uh is I mean Carlos
sorry I don't know what give both
Italians you're you're indistinguishable
bosons
um
except this Carlo has a Scottish accent
listen to Italian okay anyway uh
um
uh the uh
is is this for out of court my
understanding what you're trying to
actually stick the Tiff into the
notebook or or yes to yes to but the
idea is to minimize the size of the
images by compressing them within the
notebook well Stephen was kind of
hinting at is kind of the opposite way
not extracting them from The Notebook
and placing them somewhere else yes
which is what we want to be able to do I
mean we've got some tools for doing that
yeah as I said notebooks basically yeah
I I am kind of we're trying to figure
out exactly how this should work and I
have a branch where I'm prototyping all
of these things I think that should not
be
um so by the way could somebody get
added to the global project list this
business about handling large images in
notebooks
maybe that's Claudia's I don't know
whether you know how to do that yet but
but um
do you know how to do that do you
understand that do you not understand
somebody else here understand
yeah I can keep track of that if you
want
well it's not for you to keep track of
it goes on the global project list right
okay well Avery can help her if if she
doesn't know how to do that what we'll
we'll take care of this in our weekly
meeting tomorrow fine okay but in the
basic point is that should be a project
because it's a long-running flapping
creature okay
right it's not to be handled separately
by the project management for this
meeting it is to be handled as part of
the global project list which is a
different thing
um okay and there has several tentacles
one uh what is the representation in the
kernel and two what is the
representation in the notebook is itself
essentially image of a file sure moment
is not supported
okay and agree
uh you know we've got to have a way of
having those assets like you know like
web browsers do like website you know of
having those assets in separate files
am I making sense
and I know that John has looked at this
extensively for you know assets separate
assets for notebooks are you aware of
that Carlo
yes and those at the moment they are in
Ian has an implementation in Prototype
they are still within the notebook as
far as I know
so when you save the notebook that will
have the size of the images or whatever
asset
added into that file size but somehow
they are put in a different place in the
notebook file and so it doesn't slow
storage it doesn't slow saving down or
what
um the last I heard from Ian and maybe
Lou has more recent information is that
this still has some size limitations uh
that's not going to work then so I mean
okay let's get a separate meeting
specifically about this thing about
image size and notebooks there
yep yes
okay
and because I think we should build
something analogous to the data not
saved save now mechanism for images
which could go in the image toolbar
you know what I'm saying and the image
attached itself
did you understand what I'm saying
Lou do you understand I understand yes
although that toolbar is no longer
maintained by the front end group
I don't care um right I'm just yeah I
understand
right the okay let's look at this thing
that you're raising about the the full
expression thing
okay so it does seem useful does it not
to be able to store the full expression
in any one of these places yes or no
I think so
so I'll point out one thing when you
store it in the notebook the browse
ability of this expression is is uh
remains
um and the browsability is now depending
on the thing that you stored so if you
were to store this in a local object
then you do show more show all those
buttons would hit the local object if
you've stored in the cloud those buttons
would hit a cloud is and that's all
that's all okay hitting the cloud is
fast enough for this kind of operation
that we're happy with I mean if it needs
to have a you know a spinner that says
it's doing something then so be it all
right I just want to make sure that that
we understand I understand that full
okay I mean it's the same thing for any
of these things
right but these other guys it's just the
there are two states right during
parsing here the time would be spent
interactively
yes but I mean if show more has a delay
saying loading from cloud which I doubt
it will have because I don't think these
things are that big because the single
show more is not showing that much extra
unless there's some problem having to
load the whole thing on show more
uh I mean so I well I think if you're
still in the same session no no no no
but not in the same session it would
have to load the whole thing because
right that's basically right a short of
shallow it's like right how how does it
know you know right it's showing you the
beginning and the end right so how does
it know I don't think it can do anything
other than assume I assume it's going to
save in wxf it will probably be fairly
fast to come back in that's how it
should do it
right I mean it managed to save it in
the kernel once so it can save it in the
kernel again
am I making sense
yep
right and so should do we want to change
store to save no hold on hold on hold on
um
why aren't we using the same wording
well this is matching the the previous
Oh you mean well they did not say save
now
um
I guess we could do that
I think it's at least it's confusing to
just do that
and standardized on that
what about what about full expression
not saved just to sort of make it yeah
it is better
mm-hmm
okay and then and then the menu items
are are the same one save now and then
the icon and use the same menu items
okay
perfect and and then down at the bottom
of the foot of that setting it says
expression size might as well just say
it again even though it's going to be
probably the same site as the size in
memory
I would hope so
yep
or do you think it's not necessary is
the footer in this case because it
already said it
I'm sorry I think I missed something
okay right now it says at the beginning
of that line size and memory eight
megabytes yep okay at the bottom of the
menu it would say again expression size
eight megabytes unless we don't do that
yeah maybe we should cut it off from
that it'll be con it's confusing
see what I'm saying yeah well I'm
certainly having two different text
labels for the same information is odd
yeah so I think we should just not
include it in the menu here
on the guns that it's already included
in the footer
makes sense yep
I'm okay with that
okay
all right should we move on yep
okay new key or key value to check
arguments right so this is a specific
problem that uh you know we've run into
with using check arguments to implement
operator forms so some operators
um
like map uh some functions like map
allow options when you're using them
normally but don't allow options when
you're using it in as an operator form
and so you see you get a different
message in between the first output and
the second output that reflects the fact
that
um you know options aren't allowed in
the second case
um
and so check arguments certainly
currently doesn't have a way of of
getting that behavior right
um
and so I uh there were a couple of
proposals only one of which I actually
really like which is right we have this
options mode key to customize check
arguments which can be longest or
shortest which has to do with you know
our rules treated as as option names or
as arguments and this is getting that To
None means I don't allow options at all
yep
sounds reasonable to me okay
let me just have a quick look at what
how check arguments handles that
check arguments has an association in
that case yep
I think I could go either way with this
I don't really know I mean maybe it's
clear to have two different keys or is
it just obscure because if you give
options aloud
false then the other key is just
flapping around
right then the other key is sort of
flapping around and also you know
option you know options allowed sounds
like it might be a list of
I see which options are allowed exactly
that will be allow options
right ah yes
um
but I think options mode to none is okay
okay
um and I wonder why is the heads not I
feel like uh oh no I'm sorry I'm
confusing it with arguments options
never mind
um
okay so this is a big thing which you
know we may not want to get into now
um but uh
uh right there was uh there was some
discussion and you know there was an
email thread and you
uh said we should discuss
and
I mean so the basic problem is
um let me try and state a version of
this problem okay
first point is right now background is
just a color yep
I have been asking for like a decade
more than a decade to have background be
able to be an image I agree
I think that's the direction we would
like to go I think this was me thinking
out loud that maybe an infinite sphere
that was textured would be a thing but I
don't think it's the right approach I
think a background the the background
option could be more flexible don't know
what's involved in implementing that but
I that's the right recognition perhaps
even support tiles
right well I mean this question of how
background Works versus how texture
works on a polygon versus those kinds of
things is subtle
and maybe we don't have the right set of
people here but I I think the correct
thing here
is that
you know background quite globally
whether it's for a cell in a notebook or
whether it's for a graphics object
should be capable of being an image
right which there's there's two things
one is just just back on supporting
images when it's 2D which is fine
then there's then there's background
sporting images when it's 3D
um even in 2D it's not obvious what to
do because what what what is the size of
you know how does it scale the
background sure
certainly if we're going to start this
more General discussion then I would say
we should postpone it until John is
actually not on PTO it's not only John
who's needed Brett is also needed was it
well Brett is here okay well maybe he
could have pine on this because I think
we should start thinking about this
because background there is an image
that is for example square but then it's
going to be the background for plot that
is you know golden ratio aspect ratio
what does it do
four or five different approaches that
things take
right and I mean we already have you
stretch a clip in one way you tile
right so we already have some options to
other functions that do those kinds of
things don't we
have some examples
you know image padding I'm pretty sure
has that mm-hmm
and it doesn't image padding actually
allow a background image to pad with
um image padding is an option
um is it pat image or imagery size or
what am I talking about
maybe because also there may be related
question which is in a 3D case what
projection do you assume the image is
using and orientation indeed this is
this is the case here image pad
yes
I I argue this is actually analogous to
the projection rotation issue
let's talk about that as soon for a
second so
the question is you rotate the object
what happens to the background is that
one question well no no so there's
there's two questions well okay I guess
that's one I mean the background could
be fixed or it could move I was assuming
it would move but but the
the moment it was the fixed Stars
right okay so if it's the fixed stars
then there's two things one the texture
you give for the background what
projection are you giving your texture
in that's one question but then the
second is uh which part of the texture
is facing
or something right
well how we defined that I mean so
you know this is what spherical image
and other related things was supposed to
deal with
I believe
and it's something for which Astro
Graphics has
you know astrographics Paints the fixed
Stars on
the celestial sphere so to speak
is that not correct correct yes so I
would expect that we provide a correct
angular image
and that then it's converted effectively
into something that looks orthographic
because it's at infinite distance
and
yeah so that means wait a minute does it
distort or does it not distort it it
doesn't I mean
it doesn't distort with respect to the
view that you expect in 3D
okay of course because what we provide
originally was distorted because it was
a standard equirectangular thing I see
but I don't see any other easy way of
providing it we cannot provide you know
a circle image or something like that
would be too difficult right right I
mean this then relates closely to the
spherical image problem
yes and for example the the in wfr we
have a spherical image function that
gets at a rectangular image
and and puts it on a sphere
okay
what's that function called
a spherical image I think
um
let me just uh set up for a second okay
the the
different thing in Astro is that we want
this fear to be at Infinity
rather than the geocaches how is this
useful I don't understand this picture
so that that's I mean if if you run that
in a notebook then you can click on that
image and move it
you know one thing that just drives me
bonkers is the fact that the click to
copy here isn't
doesn't have this inclusion click to
copy inclusion what's happened to that
that that should be another thing on our
project list by the way YouTube copies
both lines yeah yeah that has an option
one of that the person who made the
notebook should have just included them
both in one cell well except we don't
need we don't want that we want to
multicellular
implied copy
okay so now what can I do here oh wow
cool
okay so your rotation Mode's probably
not quite right but it's the basic Point
yeah
it's kind of reversed you know you're
moving your mouse up and the sky is
going down so well but that's probably
what you if you imagine there was a 3D
object in the middle of it then isn't
that the direction you'd expect
this is like a trackball
of some kind
I mean I think it doesn't seem wrong to
me there's different rotation controls
through the method option that could be
specified did not have the reverse
Behavior but
you know if I think of this as like
looking through a telescope
that's telescopes flip things around no
I I'm talking about a non-reversed image
but the point is you know you you move
your telescope right you expect to see
things to the right and you're getting
the opposite of that here you drag your
mouse to the right I expect to like grab
a hold of the sky and move it off to the
right and you get the opposite here
that's a minor configuration it is it is
it's it's a minor thing yes
telescope in this picture
inside those uh
inside structures inside those
structures okay I don't I don't know
which telescope this is actually there's
the southern
European Southern Observatory I thought
telescopes usually had domes so they
could point in different directions yeah
these days I think they're not
traditional domes
um
okay but the point is this thing
I don't even know what the heck this
thing is this thing you're saying the
original image if I look at I am I am
g360
yes so that's in a rectangular thing and
oh
okay
yeah so I think this is the right thing
you provide an equal rectangular image
and then something takes charge of
projecting it appropriately
although there's a focal length this
year right how much of the image you're
going to see and things like this
yes so it's an aperture yes what is the
yeah there's the field of view but then
there's also can you look straight up in
the spherical image
the question would be whether or not I
mean the pixels would all be crunched at
the near the top
no this is done differently so these um
what this down here is to have um
desolation of the sphere into many
polygons and then pieces of the image
are projected on those polygons
that's why there are no effects of
accumulation at the top
I don't understand up here
this thing right why doesn't the same
star get copied many times at the top
what I'm saying is that if we do that if
we did a parametric plot 3D then we
would see effects of of many pixels
accumulating at the at the at the North
Pole which is I think what Christopher
was commenting Yep this is avoided here
by using a different method so first the
sphere is tessellated into thousands of
polygons
and then pieces of the image are
projected onto those polygons so nothing
special
is happening at the North Pole the North
Pole just has another polygon
I'm confused which which piece of this
Top Line is the North Pole
the whole line
but but this whole line has different
stars at different places so why doesn't
that you know why doesn't that confuse
the question of what's at the North Pole
well if the equity rectangular
projection of this image is well done
then it should happen that the very same
star is at the North Pole it's just that
probably the sky doesn't have
any exact star adenos ball
I said so you claim it's black there but
if there were a star at the North Pole
the whole of that that the light of that
star will be will be spread across will
be copied across that Top Line exactly
so when that star
its brightness would be
you know it'd be shattered into pieces
and then its brightness will be averaged
over those pieces
right so it would not accumulate right
because you would have it wouldn't be
that the brightness is there will be a
copy of the star many many times here
yep
yeah so what I'm saying is that this
function has a method of dealing with
that that is non-trivial I'm better than
a simple let's just put all those pixels
at the same place
yeah I get it
okay
well okay so so then we basically we've
got to take image okay thinking about
background first question is there are
zillion functions that have a background
option
I think from you know from framed to all
kinds of things like should framed allow
a textured you know background I think
yes an image background
actually when I said textured background
what about things like filling patterns
and so on
those are part of Graphics so in general
one could imagine the background could
have either an image or a graphics
do people agree
yep
so presumably with additional metadata
though to say what to do with that image
well exactly that's what image pad has
to do right now right the image pad has
to tell one you know does it do this
this this this this
makes sense
yep
and I mean and it's also got to have
like inset it's got to have a way of
deciding you know where to place that
image relative because image pad doesn't
have that issue because it's just
putting padding on the sides
um
all right this probably is another thing
for the global project list because it
goes across a bunch of different groups
and a different bunch of different
places this would be a lovely thing to
have I mean
to me even doing it in the 2D case is
highly interesting the 3D case
seems what what are the immediate use
cases of a 3D case
for us is just Astra the the
having an easy way to put this
background image
of the universe now perhaps slightly
related maybe not would be Jose for you
to have a Geographics 3D but that's kind
of like more like a Google Earth thing
where yes it's not a background in that
case you're kind of looking down on a
textured sphere that's very different in
depth because the sphere is finite it's
a finite distance and we need to control
what it is and we want to have things
just in front of it
right it's not really a background right
for a future Geographics reading
all right well something to look at so
we need to discuss this with John and
others
but a good thing for us to have
and um
yeah I mean there'll be a bunch of
subtle issues but you don't need this
fraster because Astro Graphics already
has a mechanism for dealing with this
doesn't it yes the 2D case we handle
ourselves Jeff is asking Jeff is
thinking of the future 3D case right I
have a kind of a prototype of an astro
graphics 3D in the form of a wfr called
telescope view 3D and you can say you
know telescope view 3D of Mars and it
shows you the current 3D orientation of
Mars as seen from Earth or from the moon
or from wherever you want to be but
there's no background it's just a black
Sky I don't have an easy way of putting
stars behind Mars in 3D
I think you should solve that as a
custom thing before I mean to me the
spherical image thing
is really its own thing intended for VR
type thing right and I mean that that um
format whatever it is the USD format or
something
is that relevant to this or is that
something different the USD format is
what we need you know what we can now do
with with ar publish and so on
I don't know whether that relates to
this
this may be yet something different do
you know
I'm not from enough USD well that's what
we just added in 13 3.
so my understanding from Charles is that
uh you know this sort of uh
um
you know that
yes the the right this sort of uh you
know right they call it a sky box and it
sort of exists in USD and sort of game
engines
um okay this image at infinite distance
obviously we were able to put our
background on on that then people could
Orient their mobile phones and see the
stars that correspond today
orientation well let's see if we can
figure out how to do that that would be
very nice
all right I should run here
um
good stuff thanks guys we more or less
got through the agenda
good work
thanks for the comments on the live
stream thanks